lundi 3 mai ce jour est celui de la
première étape du déconfinement c'est la
fin de la limite des 10 km et plus
besoin d'attestation en journée pour les
professionnels du tourisme cette date
est importante
la seule interrogation les clients
reviendront-ils ça dépend de la volonté
de chacun et de ceux qui ont besoin de
de sortir de leur appartement en fait
qu'ils ont besoin de voir un peu de
verdure
alors oui ils pourront nous ils
commencent à nous appeler pour les
week-end qui arrive ici avant la crise
les clients étaient principalement des
hommes d'affaires maintenant compte
davantage de personnes en déplacement
pour des chantiers mais aussi des
franciliens qui ont besoin d'air autre
grande date le 19 mai réouverture des
commerces des lieux culturels et des
terrasses avec un couvre feu à 21h les
avis illinois sur ce calendrier sont
mitigés si les gens se protègent avec
des masques et 6 des toits bien démarré
tout ça ça doit pas poser de problème
simplement c'est la vaccination qu'il
faut que absolument qu'il soit on se
vaccine je trouve que c'est un peu trop
tôt je trouve qu'il faudrait qu'on
libère certaines choses où il ya
vraiment moins de risques possibles voir
la situation commencera et bien après
aller au delà
nous avons attendu et nous avons donné
des efforts et aujourd'hui tout le monde
doit profiter de ça le couvre feu sera
repoussé à 23 heures le 9 juin
cette date marquera aussi la réouverture
des salles de sport avec un respect des
jauges un soulagement pour les gérants
d'établissements sportif la première
impression qu on a juste et le uss enfin
on a pu enfin avoir une vision avoir une
date
donc ça c'était le jeu la chose qu'on
attendait plus qu'on a été
malheureusement entre kim et balades et
de date en date c'était décembre puis
début janvier puis fin janvier
mi-février pour après dire ben on verra
plus tard
donc là sera moi un ouf de soulagement
la fin du processus de déconfinement
devrait avoir lieu le 30 juin avec la
levée du couvre-feu des ajustements
pourraient avoir lieu en fonction des
situations sanitaires locales
seuls les discothèques resteront fermés